well this is a Fox News Alert and
certainly surprising a federal judge in
Texas has just struck down Obamacare
true story judge Reed O'Connor says the
individual mandate the part of the law
that requires you to participate is in
constitutional and because it cannot be
separated from the let rest of the law
which it cannot be the entire law is
invalid now the individual mandate
you'll remember was previously upheld by
the Supreme Court but on the grounds
that it was a tax the fine for not
following the mandate was eliminated
last year so O'Connor says this makes
that ruling invalid because it's no
longer a tax the ruling is certain to be
appealed appealed obviously Obamacare by
the way was passed on March 21st 2010 it
was signed three days later Wow
didn't see that coming we'll continue to
follow it obviously